bien alors maintenant c'est son affaire
1 qui jusque là maintenant on va faire
une interview première fois on ne bouge
pas pour le dîner sa holding
alors interview première fois vous êtes
concentré de leur s à
attention attention attention attention
premier souvenir ça commence soft
premiers souvenirs de votre vie mon psy
qui me vient c'est une petite cabane à
trinidad où j'ai vu mon arrière grand
mère avec plein de petits poussins
jaunes et moi qui étais dans l habiter
dans un espèce de petit cabanon et
jallet derrière danse impro piquer ses
poudres
ouais déjà pour maquiller ouais j'ai dit
non c'est pas ça j'ai dit on commence
soit effectivement l'a6a et bon premier
choc choc quand ma mère sortait en boîte
de nuit j'étais très très jalouse
j'avais déjà sept ans elle sortait bon
avec des amis mais je me rappelle et je
comprenais pas pourquoi moi je pouvais
pas y aller
première balle mon père la seule fois
qui m'a giflé c'est je pense est une
adolescente insupportable une fois je
pourrais j'ai fait des choses terribles
et là je lui avais dit que j'ai pas pris
mais mes devoirs de maths j'allais pas
les faire de toute façon mais après ma
série mamie contre le mur c'est une bas
mais d'ibiza le voir mais pour admettre
qu'ils étaient un peu baba pourquoi il
n'était pas là c'était génial vraiment
génial et je le remercie vous en garder
un bon souvenir s'y perdre
vous n'êtes pas devenu maso quand même
nom mais j'aime quelqu'un qui connaisse
j'aime pas un homme qui se laisse faire
non je l'avait poussé à cette vraie
premier objet fétiche objet fétiche un
soutien gorge avec des pois bleus dessus
ça monte doucement premier péché pouvait
tout dire le monde juniors est parti
mentir a augmenté beaucoup à descendre
et monter un petit ballon c'est fini pas
tout à fait premier flirt premier flat
dans le sud ouest à présent je me suis
fait un bref c'est un garçon de 18 ans
qui pensait que j'en avais 16 oui
c'était votre premier rhum après annonce
non un baiser je trouve ça vraiment
premier rang il se dit un premier homme
c'est bien plus tard
première femme très bien non un petit
baiser
premier vrai amour je pense il a été
plate onic mais j'en étais malade
première culture première rupture
je suis encore avec l'homme que j'aime
donc la main à lui bon ben on va rentrer
voilà bon ben voila c'était tout le
monde en parle
rendez vous samedi prochain
première fois trois jamais à 4 jared
sera le premier vive premier livre dont
je me souvienne c'est à 12 ans et
l'idiot de dostoïevski vous initier à
dostoïevski à 12 ans il remercie encore
ah ouais ça a du bon les papa baba ali
fameux première cuite au ccc un nouvel
an dernier il a écopé du coi du
champagne du vin rouge est un cocktail
que master à préparer c'était un truc
caïpirinha trucs comme ça vraiment
j'étais pas bien premier pétard je fume
pas de cigarettes donc à chaque fois que
j'essaie je mets tout pendant une
demi-heure donc menteuse je sais
dolores chaplin box sur une civière
ça avance l'audience 800 lucifer je
dorme